let's jump to one more thing because
yesterday
um Joe Biden fell and we are literally
at any moment one second away from
president Kamala Harris so uh I'm sure
most people have seen the video already
but take a look
[Applause]
you know what Connor I actually want to
throw back to it for one sec because I
want people to notice that when he tried
to get up initially he could not get up
on his own I don't know if he has any
public appearances today maybe you guys
know can we google that actually see if
he has any public appearances he does
yeah he does have some he's giving a
speech about the debt ceiling deal like
this uh early afternoon mid-afternoon
evening okay I'm glad to hear that the
guy's the president of the United States
I certainly don't want president miles
but could you throw to it one more time
because I don't think this was as
nothing as it just appears you know if
somebody just trips
[Applause]
thank you
yeah I mean he wasn't going to get back
up uh Libby look I know none of us are
big on his policies and the people
watching this are not big on his
policies and everything else but but
this is really getting depressing at
some level right
yeah I when I saw this fall I was
actually worried about him we know what
happens when elderly people fall it
often signals a decline that they never
recover from so I was glad to see that
he was able to get up even with help I
was glad to hear that nothing was broken
I do not want president Kamala Harris
she makes absolutely no sense when she
speaks she would just try and solve
things with a bunch of you know
confusing Venn diagrams that only she
understands a whole big laughing about
nothing it would be very confusing so I
do hope that Biden makes it of course as
I'm sure we all do to the uh to the end
of his term
um but yeah whoever put that sandbag
there probably should should not not be
permitted to put things near the
president anymore
um and it was disconcerting that he
wasn't able to get up I think that does
signal some concern about his physical
health that being said he falls down all
the time right I mean we did see the um
that bike accident where he just totally
went down I would prefer a president who
doesn't just go down and have trouble
getting up though
yeah I'm telling you right now my
prediction is this I mean first off
we're a year and a half away so God only
knows what could happen to him in in the
meantime falling whatever else is going
on with him Etc I'm telling you if
DeSantis is the nominee they are
replacing Biden there is no way they
will let him on the stage with Ron
DeSantis they will let him on the stage
with Trump which won't be good either
but that is just my my bold prediction